Tim: Good morning and welcome. My name is
Tim Caspar. I work at Hillsdale College, where
I serve as Associated Vice President for external
affairs, and deputy editor of 'Imprimis'.
I also have the privilege of teaching in the
politics department. I'm also a graduate of
the college 1994 which is 21 years ago in
May, starting to seem like a long time ago.
Mowing over themes like the passage of time
and advancing age reminded me of one of my
political heroes who Charles Krauthammer mentioned
last night, Ronald Reagan. Reagan was constantly
fending off concerns about his age with grace
and humor during the 1980 campaign. When the
issue came up again in 1984, he made a point
of saying famously during a debate with Walter
Mondale, "I will not make age an issue of
this campaign. I'm not going to exploit for
political purposes my opponents' youth and
inexperience." Again, welcome. I'll be your
MC today. Welcome to this 'National Leadership
Seminar’ in Churchill's true greatness lessons
for today.
Before introducing our first speaker, I'd
like to point out that the college has a literature
table set up out in the hallway. You can find
information out there about many college programs
on and off campus. You can also find copies
of 'Imprimis', the college's national speech
digest. I'm happy to report that the monthly
circulation of 'Imprimis' has grown from a
few thousand in 1972 when it began to over
2.9 million today, and we have our sites set
on on three million. (Applause)
Our first speaker today is Barry Singer. Mr.
Singer is the proprietor of Chartwell Booksellers
in New York City, the only standing bookshop
in the world devoted to the writings of Winston
Churchill. As a book seller, he has handled
first editions of all 42 books that Winston
Churchill published in his lifetime. I made
a point to ask him at dinner last night if
the number 42 is correct. He assured me Richard
Langworth would agree.
He's also handled many of the most significant
Churchill rarities to come to light over the
past three decades, including a long-lost
handwritten manuscript for a work of fiction
and short story entitled, 'On the Flank of
the Army'. Mr. Singer writes extensively on
the arts for numerous newspapers and magazines,
and he is the author of several books on the
subject, including 'Alive at the Village Vanguard',
which won an ‘ASCAP Deems Taylor Award’
for excellence in music writing. His latest
book, 'Churchill Style: The Art of Being Winston
Churchill' is his first on the subject of
Winston Churchill. The book's theme as he
writes in his introduction is "The artistry
he employed in constructing his day-to-day
life." This theme is the subject of his presentation
today. Please join me in welcoming Mr. Barry
Singer. (Applause)
Barry: Good morning.
Audience: Good morning.
Barry: Thank you very much for coming out
so early to listen to me talk to you about
Winston Churchill in the morning. I'm delighted
to be here. Winston Churchill would not have
been. Winston Churchill was not a morning
person. He worked at night. He worked until
very late into the night, usually dictating
his speeches, his books, his magazine articles
to a rotating retinue of very dizzy secretaries
who tried to keep up with him.
He went to bed late, and he didn't rise until
probably around this time, if not little later.
When he did, he was brought the morning papers,
every one of them on this. This is one of
many bed trays that Winston Churchill employed
throughout his life. I found it in the attic
at Chartwell. They would bring him the papers,
and they would bring him an enormous hot breakfast.
I hope you had a breakfast this morning, and
remotely as large as the ones that Winston
Churchill consumed every morning.
One of his pre-war secretaries, a lady by
the name of Phyllis Moir once described watching
Churchill in the morning, "In his old-fashioned
four-poster bed, the Peter Pan of British
politics", her words, "Sitting up, tufts of
red hair standing up from his head, scanning
closely the morning newspapers with a cigar
in his mouth." It can seem as though Winston
Churchill emerged on the world staged during
World War two more of less conjured by central
casting and full costume … The hat, the
bow tie, the overcoat, the cigar, the V sign.
Very theatrical. In fact, Winston Churchill
spent a lifetime preparing for this role.
The character and the creation were all his,
the consummation of a 65-year evolution.
As a proprietor of 'Chartwell Booksellers',
my tiny Churchill-centric bookshop in New
York City, for 32 years now been immersed
in all things Churchill. I've handled and
at least fleeting read everything that he
wrote and just about everything that was written
about him. All that time, it never occurred
to me that I really might have anything to
add to the voluminous amount that has been
written about Winston Churchill, until one
day, it occurred to me that I did, 'Churchill
Style: The Art of Being Winston Churchill'
which fascinated me. The more I learned about
him, and I do still learn something new about
him just about every day, the more fascinated
I became with the singular manner in which
he lived his life away from politics. His
lifestyle I believe was cunningly constructed.
It was no accident to nurture him and to sustain
him in a way that I can only describe as holistic.
"Yes, Mr. Churchill was easily satisfied with
the best", as his friend, Effie Smith once
said about him. This was a quote that came
to be attached to Winston Churchill, but it
was the first Lord Birkenhead, his close friend,
Effie Smith who said it about him. This does
not in any way dismiss the quotation. It was
true, but the elements of Churchill Style
seem to me to constitute a great deal more
than merely a lavish leisure life. One quote
from all the endlessly quotable things that
Winston Churchill did in fact say stands out
for me, "As one's fortunes are reduced, one's
spirit must expand to fill the void."
He wrote these words in a letter to his wife,
Clementine in 1915 from the trenches in France,
where he'd volunteer to serve after being
ousted his first Lord of the Admiralty over
the disaster at Gallipoli for which I believe
he was unfairly scapegoated. Imagine, as "One's
fortunes are reduced, one's spirit must expand
to fill the void form the trenches on the
Western front." I think it is a magnificent
maxim to live one's life by, and Churchill
did. Now, by my count, he lost at least five
elections in his terribly bumpy political
career. Each time that he was driven from
office, Churchill found something new in his
private life to embrace that nurtured him,
and I believe rejuvenated him for the next
public battle.
After his resignation as first Lord, in the
teeth of World War one, he discovered painting
as a pastime. This is one of his palettes
also buried in the attic at Chartwell. For
the rest of his life, he painted as a respite
from the world of politics. I just want to
point out here also, when I first saw this
picture of him, this was a cartoon that ran
and punch in the 1920s. I thought that was
a bottle of wine or a whisky that was next
to him, which would have been appropriate.
Although, I don't think Churchill would have
actually painted with a bottle next to him,
but if you look closely, it says, 'Turpentine'.
After the tragic death of Winston Churchill's
two-year old daughter from illness in 1921,
he bought Chartwell. This is how it looked
when he first saw it, a rather ramshackle,
old country house in Kent, that Clementine
Churchill was desperately convinced would
ruin them. Churchill redesigned it, and slowly
rebuilt it very much with his own hands, turning
it into an oasis that he retreated to for
the rest of his life. He cultivated roses
and butterflies at Chartwell, with the intensity
of a full-time naturalist. He became so adept
at bricklaying that he actually joined the
bricklayers guild. They were not actually
that happy to have him.
He was a staunch, anti-labor right, and I
don't believe he ever attended a meeting,
but he did get his guild card. I've seen it.
Churchill played polo competitively until
he was 52 years old. He rode horses into his
80s. Bear in mind, as a young subaltern, he
was a cavalry officer. He built a horse racing
stable that enjoyed great success on the track
in the 1950s, much of it after his retirement
as Prime Minister. I adore that picture. I
think it's just beautiful. That's taken at
Chartwell.
He also smoked and drank. Did you know? He
did. He was a cigar epicure, and a champagne
aficionado whose greatest passions were Cuban
cigars and Pol Roger's champagne. He kept
his cigars in a small room on the second floor
at Chartwell between his bedroom and his study,
in boxes marked "You can't make this stuff
up", wrapped, naked and large for identification
purposes. Though, he received cigar cutters
as gifts, he did not use them. Churchill prefer
to gash his cigars at the tip in a small V-shape
appropriately, or he would pierce the cigar
with a large match, and then blow through
to create a passage.
Pol Roger was Winston Churchill's parents'
favorite champagne. He inherited the preference,
and then like so much else in his life, he
bettered them. He bought staggering quantities
of Pol Roger from the family wine merchant,
Randolph Payne & Sons at 61 St. James's Street.
This is just one and an early one at that
of a massive number of invoices that have
been preserved at the Churchill archives at
Churchill College Cambridge. It was a delight
to run through them, but also rather frightening.
He would buy a Pol vintages.
After a [virtue 00:12:03] of a lifetime of
drinking Pol Roger, Churchill finally met
Madame Odette Pol-Roger, the doyenne of the
champagne-making family at a British embassy,
armistice party in Paris in 1944. He would
later say that he was as captivated by Madame
Odette Pol-Roger's elegance and beauty as
he was by the champagne served at lunch that
day, Pol Roger 1928 which was his favorite
vintage. Churchill instructed the British
Ambassador, Alfred Duff Cooper to invite Madame
Pol-Roger to the embassy every time Churchill
was in Paris. Over the ensuing years, he would
dine with her at Buckingham Palace, he would
host her at Chartwell and at number 10 Downing
Street, and he visited her at the Pol Roger
Chateau at Epernay which Churchill called
'The world's most drinkable address'. He even
named one of his race horses after her, and
one of her champagne vintages after him.
An interesting point to make about Winston
Churchill is that he very much enjoyed the
company of beautiful and intelligent women.
He love to bring them to his table. He kept
many, many close correspondences even with
old flames who had rejected him when he'd
propose marriage to them as a youth, but maintain
these very, very close friendships. Yet, as
far as I can tell and any other researcher
or a biographer can tell, Winston Churchill
never strayed from his marriage, probably
unique in the annals of British Politics.
He appears to have had no mistresses, but
he did have close friends. He enjoyed the
company of women who had something to say.
His favorite whisky was Johnnie Walker Black
Label or red. Hine was his favorite cognac.
It's interesting to note that although he
was a champagne aficionado, according to Christopher
Soames, his son-in-law, he didn't particularly
care about the caliber of cognac that he drank,
and at Chartwell, Soames often decanted into
this. I couldn't believe, but I found this
decanter at Chartwell, the excellent vintages
of cognac that Churchill was presented with
by admirers, and replaced them with lesser
quality cognac which Churchill drank and enjoyed.
Now, I must confess to you, the original subtitle
for my book, 'Churchill Style', was 'Living
Well Beyond Your Means'. It truly was and
I was dissuaded from this by Sir Martin Gilbert
who said, "You can't."
However, Winston Churchill had a very hard
time holding on to money. His singular gift
I believe was a stalwart ability to live as
he wished, even if it was often beyond his
means. This was not solely a gift for extravagance,
nor did it ever quite ruin him. Churchill
simply knew how he wanted to live, and throughout
his long life, was endlessly resourceful in
finding ways to do so. He dressed above all
else for comfort, yet, he wore bespoke everything.
He preferred to slip in and out of his clothes,
his dress shoes were made with zippers, not
laces, custom made, and after retiring his
Prime Minister in 1955, he practically lived
in his monogrammed slippers, these monogrammed
slippers which were of course hand-made.
The supreme example of his zipper-driven fashion
sense however was the siren suit that he himself
designed, a zip-up, all in one that his children
refer to as his 'Rompers'. Though ideally
suited to hurried dressing at the sound of
an air raid siren, the siren suit was in fact
conceived during Churchill's wilderness years
in the 1930s in imitation of the boilersuits
that the bricklayers wore, who he worked with
and admired so much. He however had a number
of these made up for him by the bespoke tailors
Turnbull & Asser in different fabrics for
different activities. One in blue, another
green, and this burgundy velvet for formal
occasions. He wore this with metals.
He had a business like Blue Surge, and of
course, one constructed of [smack 00:16:55]
material for painting. Generously cut with
breast pockets and roomier side pockets pleats
to the trousers and fold over cuffs, these
siren suits were in apotheoses of a simple
practicality and fashion and comfort. We see
Churchill here demonstrating the siren suit
to General Eisenhower who looks fascinated.
As who wouldn't be?
The cook is going. Winston Churchill wrote
to Clementine in March, 1935. She sent in
her spoon and ladle on her own account, "I
am very glad. She had the knack to the highest
degree of making all food taste the same,
and not particularly good. I subsist on soup.”
These come from the kitchens at Chartwell.
I think they're very handsome.
The Churchills eventually found a wonderful
new cook, a woman by the name of Georgina
Landemare, who was the wife of Paul Landemare,
the head chef at the Ritz. When Churchill
returned as first Lord of the Admiralty in
1935, Mrs. Landemare offered her services
to the Churchill family. This was an extraordinary
gesture on many counts, but particularly because
she was the most in demand catering chef in
London for all the finest dinner parties,
country house lunches. She was a very, very
important chef to the social scene, and she
was giving up an enormous amount of money
to come work for the Churchills.
She took up residency first the Admiralty
House, and then followed them to number ten
when Churchill became Prime Minister, working
miracles in a tiny basement kitchen at number
ten that was a dangerous war zone. The building
was twice hit during the blitz, direct hits
that almost brought the kitchen down, and
there were fatalities in that kitchen. She
worked there throughout the war, never sleeping
until the Prime Minister did, which was a
difficult task, and always rising before he
did which was not that difficult. She would
cook for the Churchills until her own retirement
in 1954 when she wrote this delightful cookbook.
Now, for many years, I've been saying truthfully
that I've only seen this cookbook a couple
of times. It's very rare, very hard to find,
and very charming, and if you see it, you
should gran it. I have recently learned that
the Imperial War Museum, I'm delighted to
say is reissuing it in May in a paperback.
You will be able to purchase it either in
London or at Chartwell Booksellers, and I
recommend it.
Churchill's preferences in food. People often
ask me this question. They were fairly constant
as you might imagine. “In soup, only clear
broths. It must be limpid", he once said.
In seafood, oysters and caviar, lobster and
dressed crab and scampi, dover sole and trout.
He did eat fish quite a bit, but meats, he
ate quite a bit of roast beef, shoulder of
lamb and Foie gras his favorite pudding, Yorkshire
his favorite cheese, gruyere, and his favorite
dessert, yes, chocolate éclairs.
Even more than eating though, Churchill love
to talk around the dinner or lunch in table.
Conversation at table I believe was his greatest
sport and pastime, a means of simultaneously
relaxing and sharpening his thinking, of letting
down his guard and taking in new information
from his guests. This delightful photograph
was taken at Chartwell in 1928 literally by
someone, a secretary who jumped up in front
of the table and snapped it in a moment. We
see Churchill staring straight at us. To his
right is the painter, Walter Sickert who was
a mentor and a tutor to Churchill. Churchill
had a number of great painter mentors who
helped him with his painting.
To Sickert's right is Clementine Churchill
in the hat, Diana Churchill their eldest daughter
beside her, a very young and quite adorable,
Randolph Churchill center, and Prof. Lindemann.
Frederick Lindemann sits to Randolph's right,
the gentleman with the mustache. He was Churchill's
... One of his closest confidants, and his
man for all things scientific and technological.
Lindemann practically lived at Chartwell,
and even was given a post, an official poster
in World War two, and helped Churchill device
a number of the very clever and often intricate
technological innovations that I wouldn't
say that he designed them, but he certainly
would push for them and inspire them in his
staff, including the floating bridges that
were used, the floating landing pads that
were used at D-Day invasion. Prof. Lindemann
was a very important part of that.
Beside Prof, sort of glaring askance, looking
slightly askance is Eddie Marsh who was Churchill's
longest lived in terms of service, private
secretary and a very important man in his
life for many years. Beside Eddie Marsh is
Diana [Mitford 00:22:39] who was another one
of those beautiful and intelligent women that
Churchill just enjoyed having around at table,
and next to her is Thérèse Sickert, Walter
Sickert's wife. Churchill believed in face-to-face
conversation more than anything else, and
the power of his own personal charm. During
World War two, his appetite for conversation
and social contact with Stalin and Roosevelt
helped build the alliances that shaped the
outcome of the war really as much as anything
that occurred on the battlefields. I love
this picture for many reasons. One of them
is that the ring that Churchill is wearing
if you look closely is actually the cigar
band from the cigar that he is smoking.
Churchill's willingness to travel anywhere
to make this social contact throughout the
war, despite his health and his advancing
years yielded three titanic meetings of ‘The
Big Three’ as we know, Tehran in 1943 which
is pictured here, Yalta in 1945, and the final
face-to-face after Roosevelt's death with
Harry Truman and Stalin at Potsdam in 1945
as well. Churchill was often accompanied on
these travels by his wife, Clementine or even
more often by one of his daughters, Mary or
here, we see Sarah Churchill being introduced
to Franklin Roosevelt who's clearly charmed.
Churchill preferred to fly, and was a pilot
himself and one of the creators really of
the REF. He often took the controls for a
short period usually while the plane was still
on the ground. Whether flying or sailing the
Atlantic, the perils of these journeys were
enormous with his age and health adding greatly
to those dangers. None of the planes that
Churchill flew in during World War two were
pressurized.
Susceptible to pneumonia, he kept close by
him a specially constructed oxygen mask that
allowed him to take oxygen and smoke a cigar
at the same time. In Cairo, as Churchill was
about to board a small plane for a flights
to inspect the troops at El Alamein, he asked
aloud if he could spoke onboard. A young RAF
officer very nervously, and after much hesitation
volunteered to check whether the auxiliary
gas tanks were full. Churchill stopped him.
"I enjoy a cigar", he told the young man,
"But not at the risk of being incinerated."
In August, 1929, Winston Churchill embarked
on a three-month tour of the United States
and Canada by train to see the country as
he told his good friend, American financier,
Bernard Baruch to see the country and meet
the leaders of its fortunes. He was accompanied
by his son, Randolph in the riding boots,
then on the left his brother, Jack on right,
and Jack's son, Johnny. I'm afraid and I looked
this up with hope that he never made it to
Denver, though, he did come close. On September
18, 1929, Churchill received an invitation
to dine with the Mile High Club here in Denver.
Churchill cabled back a couple of days later
that he could not make it.
Now, between you and me, Churchill was at
that moment in Hollywood, being wined and
dined by William Randolph Hearst, Marion Davies
and Louis B. Mayer. This picture was taken
on a movie set that's not New York City. That's
just a set Churchill was given a tour. Churchill
adored movies. He watched them throughout
the war to relax at checkers.
He wrote screenplays in the 1930s for the
[Carter 00:27:00] brothers to make ends meet.
His most promising screenplay, none of them
were ever filmed. In some ways, the [Carter
00:27:09] Brothers were just hiring him to
help him out, but these screenplays survived,
and he did write one, and as you must know
about Napoleon. He tried to convince ... While
he was in Hollywood at a dinner party, he
spent almost the entire night trying to convince
Charlie Chaplin to play Napoleon, which seems
to me an inspired idea, and in some ways,
you have to think that Chaplin took this to
heart later on.
I'm up for ... Although I said that already,
Churchill took a number of transatlantic voyages
when he wasn't flying throughout his life,
most of them on Cunard-White Star Line ships.
In November, 1895, weeks before his 21st birthday,
he sailed to New York for the very first time
on the Cunard Royal Mail Steamship Etruria.
He did not have a very good time. He didn't
enjoy sailing at all which is ironic when
you consider he was first Lord of the Admiralty
twice.
"I do not contemplate ever taking a sea voyage
for pleasure", he wrote to his mother from
the ship. "I shall always look upon journeys
by sea as necessary evils which have to be
undergone to carry out some definite plan."
Usually, Churchill sailed on either the Queen
Elizabeth or the Queen Mary. In March, 1946,
it was the Queen Elizabeth that he took here
to the United States to deliver what would
come to be known as his 'Iron Curtain Speech'
in Fulton, Missouri.
During the course of that voyage, he agreed
that Cunard's request to publish, to write
a foreword for a war history they hope to
publish of the two queens. They were troop
carriers in the war, the largest troop carriers
ever seen, which was very dangerous as you
can imagine. They were a big target. "Built
for the arts of peace and to link the old
world with the new, the queens challenged
the fury of Hitlerism in the Battle of the
Atlantic,” Churchill’s foreword began.
“At a speed never before realized in war,
they carried over a million to defend the
liberties of civilization, to the men who
contributed to the success of our operations
in the years of peril, and to those who brought
these two great ships into existence. The
world owes a debt that it will not be easy
to ..."
As you see, Churchill paused here to change
one word in his final draft, the last word
'Repay'. Instead of “The world owes a debt
that it will not be easy to repay,” Churchill
rewrote his conclusion to read, “The world
owes a debt that it will not be easy to measure.”
I like that word ‘Measure'. In terms of
Churchill's style, it's what I was after and
what I've tried to accomplish, to measure
Winston Churchill not in terms of the debt
we all owe him as a historical figure, but
rather, to measure the man as a man, through
the extravagantly artful style with which
he lived his life, the Churchill style. Thank
you. (Applause)
Female: Thank you very much. Thank you very
much, Mr. Singer. We now have time for a few
questions. Please raise your hand, and one
of us will bring a mic to you.
Barry: No questions? We covered it. Richard.
Oh God. That's scary.
Male: Barry, you said in rummaging in the
attic of Chartwell, when did you do that and
how did you get in?
Barry: They didn't know I was there. No. I
went and asked them if I could look through
the inventories that they had of stuff that
wasn't on display, and they didn't even ... No
one really had looked at them very often before
then. I just marked up these lists, and then
they took me up or down, and we just looked
for the stuff. They have a lot of amazing
things that they became aware of themselves
I think just through our rummaging around,
and some of that stuff I think is now come
out.
I mean, when they closed up the house, Winston
Churchill owned Chartwell his entire life,
but ultimately through an arrangement that
was worked out with the National Trust, where
they basically bought the house from him in
the 1950s after he left off as his Prime Minister,
but allowed him to live there and Clementine
to live there until the end of their lives,
and when they were finished with Chartwell,
it was immediately turned into a museum. Everything
is still there. I don't know if you've been
there. I hardly recommend that you make it
a journey to Chartwell.
I can't imagine that there is another home
in the world that has the spirit so palpably
present of its inhabit or Winston Churchill.
It's really an amazing place. Rather unpretentious.
Not a grand country house, and there's a lot
of stuff in the attic.
Male: Can you talk a little bit about his
standing desk and his writing style in terms
of Churchill, and also his love of military
uniforms that I've read that he designed himself
over and above the siren suits?
Barry: He did love uniforms. It's true. In
some ways, I think he became a soldier just
to be able to wear one. He enjoyed wearing
them. He was proud of them. His designing
of the uniforms, I think he had a hand in
it, but I don't think it was a primary design
concern.
The standing desk is a fascinating thing.
The standing desk that is at Chartwell now
was a gift that the children and grandchildren
presented to Churchill to replace the one
that he really spent most of his time working
at. Churchill did work standing up, pacing
and dictating. It all came from here, and
he was improvising as he wandered. What was
really was the standing desk was a rather
short desk, just sat, laid up that a local
wood maker had built for Churchill who lived
near Chartwell. It stood on the table.
Again, very unglamorous. There's now a very
beautiful carved one at Chartwell, which Churchill
did work at, but most of his writing was at
the standing desk. He had the secretaries
who were with him. Throughout the nighttime,
he dined late, he prepared himself to work,
and then he went to work late, and he just
stood at that desk and worked. He corrected
proofs at the desk. He did very little.
Although, you see him here actually in this
photograph. It's not up right now, but the
original photograph that I had up, you just
see him sitting at a desk at Chartwell, and
he is looking at proofs, and obviously, he
sat down on occasion, but he did a lot of
work, most of his work standing up. I have
to [defer 00:34:46] to them.
Female: You said that he did not come to Denver.
Did he visit anywhere in Colorado?
Barry: No. Not that I can tell. He blew right
past the state unfortunately.
Female: What would you say inspired you to
go study Churchill?
Barry: For 32 years, I've been selling Churchill's
books. I was always intrigued by the man,
but I've learned most of what I know by working
with those books over the years. I was not
a Churchill scholar when I began. I was simply
an admirer. When I opened Chartwell, we named
the store 'Chartwell' without necessarily
having an intention initially to be a Churchill
bookshop. It's not like that was the flash
idea. It just became clear to me ...
We went to a lovely, small, select English
library style bookshop in Midtown Manhattan,
sort of an oasis, but in the first year, it
became clear to me that with the name, we
should have some Churchill books. I brought
a few in. I took a very tiny ad out at the
back of the New Yorker saying, "Write for
our Winston Churchill catalog". Which I didn't
have, but I was curious to see if anybody
would write back, and they did. It became
clear that it was something that I should
pursue which I enjoyed very much pursuing.
It couldn't have been the more interesting
or more prolific public figure.
Then, when I went to London for the first
time to start buying for the store, it became
clear to me that while every store bookshop
in London seem to have a shelf of Winston
Churchill, mo one was specializing in Churchill.
I also have a theory ... People ask me, "Still,
shouldn't there be a Winston Churchill bookshop
in London? Why should it be in New York City?"
In some ways, Churchill was far more popular
in the United States than he is in London.
We view him from the prism solely of having
saved us and the world in western civilization
World War two which is a marvelous prism to
see him through and Churchill at his best,
but that 65-year career had a lot of ... He
offended a lot of people along the way. He
stepped on a lot of feet. He changed parties.
I think that there is a consistency which
I will not get into here now, but there is
a consistency to Churchill's political positions
throughout his life, but the English see him
in a much longer view, and from a much more
weary and slightly dubious view.
Chartwell Booksellers actually belongs in
New York. Also, Churchill was half American.
Very proud of the fact. His mother was born
in Brooklyn. His grandfather, Leonard Jerome
owned 'The New York Times' at one point, and
he was very proud of the fact that he wasn't
just a descendant of the Duke of Marlborough
and a [tough 00:37:49]. He was also an American
which he thought gave him a real sense of
independence which he did have from his class
from class demands, and it's another reason
why a lot of his fellow conservative politicians
didn't trust him.
Male: I too can identify with Churchill's
habit of working at a stand up desk, and I've
done that all my life. My question is, did
Churchill's paintings have any commercial
value, and do they have commercial value today?
Barry: They have no commercial value at all
today. If you have any, please bring them
to me, and I'll be glad to take them off your
hands. Churchill I don't believe ever sold
a painting. He gave them to his family, and
he gave them to friends on occasion as gifts.
He painted over 500. Close to 550, right?
Most of those still are hanging in the painting
studio at Chartwell, though they are claimed
in some sense. Groups of them belong to different
children and now, grandchildren, and then
great grandchildren. They all remain in the
family. They are very good. Certainly not
all of the same quality, but there is a charm
and a vivacity to them, and sometimes, they're
actually brilliant paintings.
He was very good. Very prolific. He painted
to relax. He loved bright colors more than
anything else. They're very appealing, and
lately, they have begun to come on the market.
Some of the finest paintings probably that
I think we will ever see from that group of
Churchill that painted, Lady Mary Soames when
she past, the family auctioned them in December.
I went to London and went to Sotheby's before
they auctioned just to see them. I went down
in the basement, and they were just lined
up on the wall, and I just wanted to see them
before they disappeared ... Who knew where
they were going, who's going to buy them and
where they were going to go? Most of them
sold for around a million, and one of them
sold for two million, so they have become
extremely valuable and rare.
Male: Mr. Singer. Would you be kind enough
to tell us a little bit about each of Winston's
children and how they were perceived by Winston
and Clementine, and how they fit into his
life?
Barry: That's another book. In brief, Winston
Churchill doted on his children. Some would
say to an over ... He overindulged them, particularly
Randolph who he adored and took with him from
very young age. Churchill was also traveling
a lot without his children, so they didn't
see him that much. It was a very complicated
thing when he would come back home and spend
time with them. There were brief bursts.
For better of worsts, with the exception of
the youngest, Mary, they all struggled as
adults to varying degrees. Randolph is a case
study in the travails of the only son of a
great man. Randolph had a lot of gifts. Randolph
was as you can see from some of these pictures,
an extraordinarily handsome, young man. He
wanted to go into politics, but Randolph thought
he could do everything immediately. His father
had raised him in a way that he just thought,
"I can follow and better him instantly."
I would imagine that to some degree, Winston
Churchill himself was that sort of a young
man when he was coming up. This is a very
odd statement to make, but Churchill spoke
to it himself. In some ways, he was blessed
by the fact that his father died young. His
father was an enormous political figure, and
a very, very important and admired, and rather
loud political figure in London. Because he
died young, the world opened up to Winston
Churchill for him to become an individual
at a very young age, and to find himself,
and to make something of it himself because
he also was left very little money, so Churchill
didn't suffer in the way his children did
by a surfeit of too much attention.
They struggled. They all had with the exception
of Mary problems with alcohol. Winston Churchull
consumed a great deal of alcohol without having
it affect him very much if at all. His children
had affected problematically. Randolph, Diana
and Sarah were all alcoholics.
They've had a very prominent place in his
life. I think the best moment for all of them
was World War two individually. Randolph volunteered
for the most dangerous espionage missions
to prove himself, and did prove himself. Both
Sarah and Mary accompanied Churchill again
and again on these very dangerous and important
journeys, and I think were very close to him
and grew very close to him in that. Diana
was a very sad situation. She ultimately committed
suicide.
When she was in her 50s and Churchill was
past 80, it was devastating for the family.
Sarah became a very successful actress for
a while. I don't know if you've ever seen
'The Royal Family', but she danced with Fred
Astaire and held her own, but her later life
was also troubled by alcohol. It was tough.
Most people seem to feel, and I believe it's
true that Clementine devoted herself to her
husband in a singular way, because he was
a singular man and needed a lot of attention,
but neglected the children as a result. They
had to compete with him for her attention.
Complicated.
Male: Marigold?
Barry: Marigold died at two and a half of
Septostomy, and both Churchills were away
when she became ill. They had left her with
a French nanny, but ultimately, Clementine
as any mother would blamed herself for leaving
her with a nurse who wasn't able to deal with
the fact that she was ill. By the time they
got back, it was too late. A very mild child
with illness suddenly metastasized very quickly,
and she was gone. I can't even bring myself
to think ... I have two daughters, what that
must have been like for them for the rest
of their lives.
Female: Hi. Is there anybody in today's political
landscape that jumps out at you as being Churchillesque?
Barry: No one even wonders out at me. However,
I must say I was fortunate enough to spend
time with Boris Johnson, the Mayor of London
recently. When his book came out, we had a
reception for him at Chartwell, and we had
a very interesting evening where he spoke.
The man has a great deal of substance. I think
he is truly an intellectual which is very
... I can't think of enough, virtually another
politician who you can say that about today.
He knows a great deal about Winston Churchill
which endears him to me, but he also fancies
himself as Winston Churchill, and whether
that endears him to the British public remains
to be seen. He's an interesting fellow and
clownish in a way that I believe is very cleverly
conceived. He's the first person that leaps
to mind when you ask that question.
Male: You've spoken extensively mentioning
Chartwell and the events there. What role
and what events occurred at Blenheim Castle?
Wasn't this another of his residences?
Barry: It was not one of his residences, and
the only major event is that he was born there
by accident. His mother was pregnant but not
due. She was there for a weekend of parties
and riding, and she went into labor. There's
a lot to that story. You could write a book
about Jenny Churchill going into labor at
Blenheim Palace. Whether it was premature,
whether it was that Churchill actually was
being born full term, and that he was conceived
out of wedlock, there's a lot of speculation
about that. Fundamentally, in the midst of
a dance, she went into labor on I think on
a Saturday night, and they had to lay her
down in a cloakroom, and she gave birth rather
unexpectedly to Winston Churchill who burst
upon the world.
He grew up there. He did spend a lot of time
there. His parents interestingly enough were
seldom around when he was growing up. They
were very busy, socially, politically. He
was left at Blenheim Palace a lot, a terrific
place to grow up. He proposed to his wife,
Clementine at Blenheim Palace, but it was
not a residence. He didn't live there.
His father was the non-inheriting son of the
Duke of Marlborough. I think the second living
son, the third son, the son between passed
away, but he didn't ... Churchill by a long
stretch was an heir to that title but never
came close.
Male: From Churchill's art to his speeches,
his writings, where he lived, what would you
say was the theme of his life from your perspective,
and then from perhaps Churchill's own perspective?
Barry: One of themes was the richness of the
history and the language of the English-speaking
peoples. He wrote about that again and again,
and probably no one else ever wrote about
it so eloquently. I also think that a central
tenet of Churchill's life, and it's woven
into his writing is magnanimity. Churchill
had a great deal of magnanimity for his enemies.
He forgave very quickly once a confrontation
was over, and he felt that it was a central
tenet of statesmanship. He had no greater
enemy in the run-up to World War two, the
Neville Chamberlain.
Yet, when Chamberlain collapsed when his efforts
failed, and when Churchill was designated
as his successor, Churchill remained at Admiralty
House for a number of weeks to allow Chamberlain
to graceful exit number 10 Downing Street,
and then, he invited Chamberlain into his
cabinet. That was a very central tenet of
Churchill's way of viewing the world, that
we're all in this together in a sense, that
mistakes are made. They must be remedied.
They must be addressed, and then they must
be forgiven for us to live together.
On that note, let me just say that there were
a lot of things thrown around here last night
very brilliantly on Mr. Krauthammer, but there
were a lot of facts that were complicated,
more complicated and some erroneous, I only
wanted to correct two regarding Winston Churchill.
You should know that his autobiography, his
only volume of autobiography is my early life,
not my early years. It's important to remember
so you can come to Chartwell and ask for it.
The other is that when Churchill ...
This is an interesting thing just to know
that when Churchill was hit by a car in New
York City, he was not hit by a taxi. He stepped
out of a taxi cab, while looking for the apartment
of Bernard Baruch where he was going for an
after dinner drink, looked the wrong way,
and was actually struck by a small truck which
is why he almost died, but it was not a taxi
cab. Just those things were hanging around
me last night, and I wanted to share them
with you, and thank you very much for having
me. (Applause)